yo what up gq is travis scott it's my
style heroes
[Music]
my first style hero was steve jobs
you know he's most known for the
turtleneck and just the simple jeans and
some tennis shoes you know it was
simplified
but it's still like worked at the
highest degree
i mean yeah i think steve jobs is just
someone who might not be as focused on
their closet
he put a lot of his attention into like
what he was creating
and the simplicity of it all was just to
keep
personal uniform is always best always
start cartoons with like
the best things they wear the same
clothes every day
my next style hero is robin woods
robert williams is an actor and you know
one of the best ingredients
i don't know if you're surprised but
don't be surprised and i've always
thought he had some
some of the illest fits
you know he just had his own system of
style which is very personal
himself that'd just be the cool things
just like what you enjoy
what makes you happy i think i feel like
everything you wear is just makes me
just gotta dial in
he's a good actor philosopher very good
philosopher
very good motivational speaker
a lot of these are just come on his
closet the things that he probably you
know
grew into and like grew up with and you
know just things that he likes and what
makes him happy
i mean i don't think it's any personal
to like what's cool
i think it's just all personable i think
it's just his closet
what's in it it's what makes it on you
know
last but not least goldie
said fire dj rager
you know i mean you know from one ranger
to another i just thought it was always
just like
legend it was just attitude for everyone
i think everything was attitude you know
what i mean it was robin
or shaya goldie or steve jobs you know
it's the attitude you know it's not
about clothes i don't think it's about
labeling i think it's about just what
makes you happy what you put on what
what makes you feel good you know never
be scared to like you know try new
things
see what's out there make your own
things you know arts and crafts do it
yourself
like you know like just different type
of ways take something make it your own